[Music]
makes oil is a global movement asking
people to come together in their
communities in their neighborhoods
around the simple and universal act of
making soil the world is facing so many
challenges today from the environment to
social and rest to mental health to
public health nutrition and it turns out
that making soil together all of us in
our neighborhoods and our backyards and
our front yards is actually one of the
most impactful in immediately available
things that we can do to make a
difference
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on
super-pumped to be talking about
planetary interventions we have Josh
Witten joining us on the show hello hi
glad to be feeling thanks for coming on
yeah so excited for the episode those
that don't know Josh's background he's
an impact entrepreneur blending
technology and business with active care
for the planet the company's projects
and planetary interventions he serves
aim to harmonize society with nature
catalyze a regenerative economy and
elevate human consciousness projects
include the transit tech company
translocation pian of change by the
white house TransLink was number five on
Fast Company's list of the most
innovative companies in transportation
and was recently acquired by the Ford
Motor Company Josh also co-founded one
of the first urban farms in the
southeastern the United States helping
thousands of people each year to
participate in a more beautiful food
system his latest intervention is make
soil which is upgrading the global food
system by mobilizing humanity to convert
food waste into soil on a planet-saving
scale and you find the links in the by
below to make soil org as well as Josh
Winton's website and all of the other
social media links for both of them all
right let's start things off with one of
our favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world hmm well I would say that
if if you're watching this and you're
looking for something to do it's a great
time to help stabilize the biosphere and
to help expand human consciousness
because there's a lot of great things we
could get into but more and more
community are waking up to the fact that
we're sort of floating in this fish tank
and it's us in the vacuum of space and
things aren't going so well in that
biosphere so it's time to get on board
with realizing the existential threats
that face us that's my take on it so
everything I do
stabilize the biosphere expand human
consciousness I find that just about all
of my life fits into those two
categories now
so beautiful we love hearing from our
guests the focus on on raising that
level of consciousness around the planet
being really good stewards of Earth then
what are then some of these most key
practices that we can do in order to
achieve that yeah I mean everybody knows
that people are out of touch with nature
right society like most of society our
jobs our companies the end of the
economy kind of gobbles up the biosphere
right gobbles up ecosystems turns of
turns them into products and services
right so how do you start to shift that
how do you and maybe there was a time
where it didn't matter that people were
disconnected from nature because there
were like seven billion less of us or
something but now it matters and so
that's the question how do you
reintegrate people with nature and the
most practical way that I found is to
actually get people to make soil
together because if you think about it
what are we gonna do are we all gonna go
camping like and look at the Stars and
like hope that we have a some kind of
connection with nature but people do
that already they go camping they leave
the park they go back home nothing
really changes right so I'm more
optimistic now about practices that
individuals actually take in their own
lives on a routine basis that start to
harmonize their human life with nature
and it turns out there's no more ready
opportunity to do that than to Shepherd
the bits of food and nature leftover on
our plates every day back into living
soil so so one of the one of the
planetary interventions that I'm backing
is this project called make soil because
that's the one opportunity that all
humans today have an opportunity to get
in on to Shepherd those food scraps and
bits of nature and even leaves in your
backyard turn it into living soil and
that process reintegrates this nature
yeah Wow the amount of indigenous wisdom
that we've been hearing about this idea
of our disconnection from source or from
from all that is that that being nature
that being the reason why we have all
these malevolence ha's and issues with
our civilization
that one of the most active ways to
participate in reconnecting is to take
these these it's shepherding the little
food scraps leftover and going out
ourselves maybe once a week into these
communities and we'll we'll go over this
these different soil making sites around
the world now there's over 300 of these
and anywhere from once two to ten people
are participating on these sites and so
the idea is that you can then get a
deeper like when you actually put your
hands in a tin soil you feel the
microbes you feel the connection to the
food you get excited about wanting to
grow your own food a big part of this is
just children being raised in Metropolis
is away from starlight away from farms
and things growing and it's growing yeah
yeah yeah learning is in many ways a
matter of feedback loops completing
feedback loops right so the the longer
the feedback loop the harder it is to
update your mind and your brain
the shorter the feedback loop that use
here it is so you know nobody needs to
read a dissertation about not touching
hot stoves right we all did it at some
point in our in our childhood and that
was all we needed to never want to do
that again right and then we these
really more drawn-out feedback loops
like the things we eat and maybe we we
eat poorly and after a few months we
feel crappy yeah but that and that's why
that's hard because the feedback loop
was longer right and when it comes to
reintegrating with nature there's a lot
of you know documentaries and
initiatives online and people are
clicking like and but that's not really
connecting the feedback loop with nature
and of this real direct way yeah so
watching watching these bits of nature
watching the banana peel and the tea
bags and the coffee grounds and the
leaves in your yard undergo this
microbial process where they turn back
into this jet black dark living soil
that's that's so full of life watching
that process completes a feedback loop
yeah and that's actually the sneaky
thing about it is that it looks so
humble this kind of idea of getting
people to make soil together but it
turns out that it's the first
regenerative act
that most people have ever participated
in like putting in a can and a recycling
you know bin is not regenerative it's
positive you know it's better than
mining that or again it's not
regenerative so how do you start having
regenerative experiences and so creating
living soil together that's regenerative
sticking your hands in the living soil
at once it's finished the microbes in
the soil are communicating with the
living skin that you have and that
completes a feedback loop at a
subconscious level so it's really a
matter of completing these feedback
loops and so make soil is just one way
to scale that one of those most
important feedback loops yeah that's
such a good one though it seems like the
most present one that we carry with us
on a moment-to-moment basis is breath
yeah as that feedback loop and then this
thing that we do every day with the food
that we eat to then go and also make be
part of making soil in and taking us
back to our roots in that sense is this
other code like really short closed-loop
feedback cycle that we can get with
awakening ourselves back to our
connection with nature yeah I love this
I this definitely is starting to to top
my list of ways to prosper more
sustainably into our future and I wonder
what are the other planetary
interventions let's let's talk about
some of the journey that led you to this
point sure who were you when you were
kid growing up that got you interested
in planetary interventions
yeah I don't know if my childhood I mean
our childhood defines us in so many ways
mine was not easy so you know I tried
like starting little companies and
things when I was a kid and mostly like
my school teachers told me stop fooling
around and get back to studying you know
so I really it's kind of like I spent 15
years waiting for life to start and then
once I got out of the school system I
could finally get on with making the
world a better place
and learning and being curious so if
there was any contribution by my
childhood it's the fact that my my
ability to contribute and learn was so
stunted for the first quarter of my life
that once I was free I was just
voraciously learning about the world you
know and I'm into all of it right I'm
into technology ecology spirituality all
of it I just love reality so curiosity
if you leave some B's curiosity intact I
think anybody anybody who has curiosity
and a few hours of data satisfy that
curiosity they're gonna appear as a
genius within a few years because
they've just been following their
curiosity right and many many people
don't get that opportunity right now
yeah oh damn that's a good one yeah if
we have enough of the basic needs met on
the hierarchy of needs then we can
pursue our divine creative actualization
on a moment-to-moment basis then we will
look like geniuses I love that so then
okay so when you're kind of blending
together you're you know your early
years with your desire to to do
planetary interventions where does trans
look come up well let's look for the
word the phrase for as well this came up
with planetary interventions yes because
people would ask like what company are
you doing now or they say I have a
start-up or whatever and I just found
that so many companies really have no
positive mission to them I mean they
might greenwash it a little bit or say
like well we're giving people jobs and
then they can put their kids through
college but we need better reasons than
that
to create companies now right it's eight
eight billion people saying you know I'm
gonna go get a job and have a company
that doesn't do any good for the planet
it just can't handle it anymore right so
it's so I stopped calling the companies
and we're really running out of time to
do things that don't matter and that
don't make the world a better place
and we don't need more companies that
just mindlessly consume the biosphere
yes which is what they do the economy as
it is now had and has very little
understanding of of the biosphere right
it was sort of predicated on a limitless
raw material that we sell at the
greatest margin we can it doesn't cut it
anymore
so I stopped using the word companies
and started calling these planetary
interventions because it doesn't matter
to me what the vehicle is I'm agnostic
about that you know makes oils and non
profit some of my other ventures are for
profits but the vehicle could be a
podcast it could be a tweet it could be
a book it could be it doesn't matter but
we just need to make planets and we need
to make interventions we need to
intervene in the direction of society
today so that the biosphere doesn't
collapse and so that people don't keep
blowing each other up and sniping at
each other and hurting each other out of
broken minds and traumas and wounds and
things right so to me that's what's the
point of having a bunch of money in a
world where people are killing each
other and you know we're here in San
Francisco right tons of innovation and
how many bodies do I have to step over
in the sidewalk people lying face down
cracked out you know it's time to
address these things
the biosphere is not something to just
turn into a stream of financial output
but it's something to be stewards of and
yes it's in humans in humans in a way
haven't found our niche in the ecosystem
today it's like there's nature and
there's people yep right we're the only
thing that doesn't consider ourselves
part of nature except the indigenous
they right there yeah sure yeah and so
humans could be the most regenerative
yeah animal on the planet we could be
preserving speech code are already down
there waiting
yeah all types of things and then if we
embrace that identity and that
occupation we would find a lot of the
existential malaise you know being
addressed a lot of psychological issues
a lot of the social issues yep we'd have
our purpose we'd have our place in the
ecosystem damn all of the issues with
mental health with all of the this
stripping away the planetary resources
all these things are just second order
issues and third order issues from the
first principle issue which is our
disconnection from nature us and not
being able to find our place as stewards
of the planet yeah that's how the
indigenous have been describing it and
I've really enjoyed that way of viewing
it and okay so the inspiration is to
inspire other people here to get focused
on planetary interventions and not
necessarily just companies or start-ups
but things that are specifically geared
towards planetary interventions yes
aligning us in a more positive direction
in a more positive trajectory raising
consciousness yeah yeah it's like an
all-hands-on-deck situation and with
many people not aware of the challenges
facing us or or increasingly aware that
things aren't good but not knowing what
to do right there's so many
documentaries and doomsday I mean
document is are fairly fairly decent but
just as bad news everywhere right yeah
but people feel pretty disappeared to do
anything
I think that's leading to a
desensitization and a kind of repression
of the of the situation so it's time to
it's time to intervene on a planetary
scale each human can look around them
with their context their background
their intelligence and see one way that
they can make the world a more beautiful
place and if each one of us did that we
would create heaven on earth and then
you spent a good chunk of time working
on trans locus is adding technology to
make public transit better and these are
just some of the little ways that we can
do things like sea systems around us
that could use improvement and just to
make those interventions happen we don't
have to spend too much time on that but
yeah it's good that you ended up doing
that yeah and that's and that's a nice
example especially for entrepreneurs or
anybody out there wanting to make a
difference is to realize that it's kind
of it's like in the same in nature like
in nature whenever there's an edge
there's a lot of life there where
everyone ecotone meets another and in
the same way wherever any two industries
meet there's just endless innovation
that can happen there so so yeah back in
2004 when I was a college kid I would
ride the bus and realize that public
transit like didn't work that well and
then I would go play video games and
realized that there was so much
technology being brought to bear on a
fairly frivolous activity you know like
the latest and greatest in transistors
and circuitry and graphics exactly it
was all being driven by can i more hyper
realistically throw a grenade at this
Jeep that my buddy is driving from his
apartment as we're flying through you
know and you know it's just like why and
then I go wait for the bus and it was
like practically Flintstones you know it
was just like there wasn't a no circuit
you know the computer you found and I
just was like what if we took an ounce
of the technology that's being brought
to bear in the world of computers to the
world of public transport and then
you're like oh my god like these big
giant buses wouldn't move up and down
the street empty anymore
you know I like you know you would be
able to more intelligently yeah so you
see how easily it blurs right you go
from like I'm gonna apply technology to
this and now you're helping optimize
environmental issues right yeah cuz cuz
the giant bus going down the street
that's empty that's not environmentally
friendly that thing's getting three
miles to the gallon that's awful it only
makes any sense if it's full with people
yeah and that you as you know I as a
college student could be like I'm gonna
put a GPS receiver on that bus yeah you
know make the location go to an Internet
and we and my point is opportunities
like that are always all over the place
yep so it's a matter of allocating our
own consciousness and resources with
time to the ones that are most pressing
to regenerate the biosphere yeah to
become better stewards yeah yeah your
opportunity to say super easy if you
have an omnivorous mind right looking
like a broad diet
you brought diet you have a broad mental
like that and then the opportunity is to
make things better or just super obvious
if you hyper specialize it's difficult
you know yeah you're like going deeper
and deeper and deeper and now you only
you're writing a paper that only six
other people even can read and you're
trying you know it's just kind of like
that's not the highest leverage point
right now yeah I think this is first
time on the show that someone's used the
word omnivorous mind I like that yeah
it's interesting also a broad diet this
is a very Polymathic show
yeah multidisciplinary all different
types of guests so people get to have
that broad miss and diet so then after
after that then it was another planetary
intervention with make soil but an urban
farm after that oh yeah okay let's yeah
let's talk about that so that was in the
southeastern United States
where was that Raleigh North Carolina in
Raleigh okay and then there's another
simple idea it looks like people are
disconnected from the food system I was
disconnected from the food I don't know
anything about it and I started
researching it and then saw the food
system was seriously screwed up you know
it was like
being driven by commodity prices and
margins and and had lost sight of like
what was good for people to eat like
what should our bodies be composed of
seems like an important question and is
it poisoning the planet when we produce
that food these questions were of course
there were people beginning to take
issue with it but the food system as a
whole was ignorant of it and society in
general
it hasn't changed all that much so but I
just kept seeing like places in a city
where food could be grown and where
people with a little bit of time and
this is another mental barrier like so
many of our problems so many of our
barriers are just psychological barriers
right so you talk to people about
growing your own food truly I used to
mention to people especially ten years
ago growing your own food and they they
literally thought I meant that they
should quit their jobs and move to the
country and grow all of their own food
it's like no no no like can you grow a
little bit like how about a half hour a
week what if I told you you could grow
all the salad greens for your family and
a half hour a week and that it'd be fun
yeah and they're like really as people
just don't know that so I thought like
well let's let's do a community garden
and I did that with some friends and
that was amazing and this was so good
I'll say let's scale it up so then we
did a one acre urban farm right in the
middle of City so we're gonna see we're
gonna see a time where cities begin to
green up not just kind of like with
useless shrubbery we're gonna see them
producing more food and we're gonna see
more people participating in that
because the truth is that everybody
would benefit from touching something
living oh yeah during the week and ever
another feedback loop is to plant a seed
take care of it
watch what grows and then eat what grows
from it yeah and a person who's had that
experience you can always tell because
they waste a lot less food you can see
somebody who's never grown anything
because they're just like shoveling food
into the garbage when they're done
eating and it's just it's just an
abstraction to them actually here's this
is funny you're gonna love this I think
I figured out why
there's so much food waste and that's
because we all grew up watching Star
Trek and in the Star Trek all food came
from this little box that just
materialized once and I believe now
there are more living people who have
actually seen food produced on Star Trek
and have seen food produced on reality
and so now they just think they're just
scraping photons into the trash can and
it's not a big deal because there's just
a machine that'll go
powered by the lithium crystals
somewhere I'm not joking I think
subconsciously that's part of what's
going on people have witnessed that
scene hundreds of times and they've
never participated in real food
production isn't it funny I love Star
Trek but I think that's a dental
incident when you when you take and have
to take care of of plants and water them
and give them light and then try and
grow something that then you can eat
rather go buy from sir that is that is
part of our origin story and part of
some of the most important things that
every human can do and it's interesting
that you can scale it like there's this
word that I come back to it's our
ecology blending together architecture
and ecology and you see all these ideas
of future cities where there's gardens
everywhere there's massive beautiful
recycling of water and sunlight and yeah
and it's just like wow we can make that
and then we're you know and what are our
first steps were kind of image you know
that the metropolis is it's almost like
a vortex no tropi Lissa's and in the
Joker vortex of the Internet
pulling people rather than going out and
doing things so make soil seems to be
one of those very simple ways to go out
yeah and I and I love technology that
causes people to do something in the 3d
world that matters technology that just
sucks people into a digital vortex that
continues to divorce them from yeah
physical reality and all of its issues
that need attention yeah
it's not very not very healthy so
whether it was trans Luke where it's
like Wow with bits and bytes we could
more efficiently move you know millions
of tons of steel that's been yanked out
of the ground and melted into the shape
of a bus that sounds like a good idea
worthwhile to do right or with with a
website we could get millions of people
all over the world making soil out of
their food scraps that they can then
grow food in and like that seems like a
good thing to do so I love using
technology to to do that to get us to
take action in the real world I have
this funny saying that we we you know
it's building a compost bin with a buddy
and we were in Austin I buddy David and
we were driving in his like Sentra it
was a Lexus either driving his Lexus and
there's a bunch of 2x4 the two by two by
four by tens you know like all this wood
this lumber that we were hauling to
build compost bins and he's like this is
so weird you know we're like we're about
to like do stuff we're gonna build with
us like yeah we're really doing stuff
you know and it's like we cannot save
the planet entirely by tapping liking
and swiping just can't got to do
something you gotta actually do stuff
yeah yeah that right there is enough to
put the fire under the ass yeah whoo
which turns out to be more satisfying
anyway it's more satisfying it's
something in the physical world yeah
yeah whoo and there's a there's a lot of
ways to go past the tapping waking and
swiping they even just deep long periods
of I contact with others yeah there's
all different types of ways to increase
our connection to each other and slowly
butterfly effect our way to becoming
better stewards yeah but soil has a very
immediate effect
let's embodying as well right bring in
the mind into the body into the body
into yeah yes all that is um let's bring
up some of the assets that we have I
want to show the map the map of the
geographies there's so many of these
soil sites now just this first one
showcases in the in the United States
and this is on the landing page you can
create a soil site you can find a soil
site
this is about the intro video which we
played a little bit of is really great
you guys can find it makes oil dot work
alright and then on the next images that
geographies that we have this is of the
the United States Europe even South
America as well so you can see that
we're not populating these and these are
being made around from by people they're
creating their own site yeah as a new a
new one of these shows up like every day
so there's people who go to the site
maybe they're already composting and
making soil or they realize that they've
been doing it in isolation but it's time
to do it as a public service right it's
time to it's time to invite the
neighbors to make soil with you it's
it's like up people complain to me all
the time they're like oh people don't
get it politicians don't get it my
neighbors don't get and I say have you
asked them to make soil with you
yeah and I'm dead serious like you put
yourself on the map you get a little
compost bin and you knock on your
neighbor's door and say hey do you have
coffee grounds and banana peels and
stuff I would love to turn that into
soil I'm learning how to regenerate the
planet that'll change your relationship
with your neighbor they'll change the
relationship with the baby they world on
Twitter like go ask the mix oil with you
I love that ask them to make soil with
you yeah and especially in areas where
we have those big compost bins where
we're just putting in the compost and
expecting someone else in most places
that just the organics just go to the
landfill basically worldwide and in some
places they go to a curbside bin that's
kind of stinky and then gets picked up
by a truck that gets three miles of the
yellow and it takes it away and that's
better than it going to the landfill but
it's still not as great as having
beautiful relationships forming around
this regenerative act with your
neighbors and you do it I love that it
tackles that neighbor totally a phobia
that yeah yeah oh there are different
political whatever there yeah yeah I
know I know like conservative Christian
Trump supporters who are soil makers now
making soil with their neighbors you
know like the like they've you know who
think that environmental talk is like a
liberal scheme to destroy the economy
but who love the self-sufficiency that
comes
knowing how to make soil and then
anybody I don't care what your political
lines are they dissolve when you start
doing this together because now you're
doing something more fundamental than
any of that political stuff we've made
up damn yeah
damn you get so close to the origins of
the species make sure that you forget
about that's right yeah
and it brings us to I love that and okay
so the next image shows us to zoom into
the Florida area and this kind of gives
you an example a lot of these are
concentrated near Tampa yeah these are
all the different soil sites and these
are people who some of them were already
making soil I mean there's people there
who were doing amazing work this is st.
Petersburg Florida it's one of the
places where it's really taken off
that's so cool and there's people there
like like there's one lady there she's
yeah this lady she's like a yoga teacher
and the meditation teacher who quit like
you know the corporate world and she
holds soil making workshops at her house
every week and so she she like gives she
trains new soil makers right and so we
can have this just distributed you know
this is like a distributed nervous
system of humans regenerating the planet
together and it's proliferating and so
it's a decentralized system like don't
wait for make soil to come to your town
like bring make soil to your town start
it tomorrow today yeah yeah whoa
so this is one of the things if you live
in areas I think this part of the United
States has a little bit more backyard
and front yard action yeah
downtown SF yeah in Manhattan doesn't
really have too much
backyard in front yard action for this
type of projects it's unfortunate that
in many places we have paved over 100
percent of the ground instead of just
like 85% or 90% but maybe paved over the
entire thing yeah yeah but people are
reversing that slowly you're seeing
you're seeing parking lots that are
being reclaimed and turned into Gardens
or streets that are being and that again
with the transportation angle as
transportation becomes more efficient
you just won't need five lanes of
traffic plowing over the earth anywhere
yeah yeah damn yeah that's a big one
that transit with autonomous vehicles
and we're not becoming more efficient
not needing the big parking garages
turning those into Gardens that'll be a
real ailing that's very cleaning that
space putting that into Gardens yeah I
always wonder about this between housing
and the relationship between building
new housing versus just turning this
those spaces into Gardens dude yeah
that's a very interesting relationship
yeah yeah ultimately whether it's
housing here or there or rural or urban
or whatever it doesn't really matter
what matters is that you have people who
know how to live among nature in a
harmonious way yeah and when we build
cities to build them with our ecology
and - ecology and mind yeah live
harmoniously with nature yeah so you
also have this is cool it starts
breaking down like how many soil makers
there are what they accept as as things
what you don't accept so people can know
what to not bring yeah yeah and that's
and that's a part of what's clever about
make soil is we're we're we're branding
this movement in the way it's never been
done before so you see there the soil
maker this one soil maker there's nine
soil supporters like the soil maker is
essentially just a regenerative job that
I like made up a couple years ago I
would just like the soil maker like I
saw it you know and and it makes a big
difference you know the ego needs an
identity I don't mean that in a negative
sense we're always kind of like
upgrading our identity and so to go from
a planet wrecking consumer or whatever
kind of shadow identity we have right
now as a species - like I'm a soil maker
already that lifts the system right and
then there's kids and other people mean
like oh that sounds cool maybe I want to
be a soil maker - right so you give that
an identity and you give the neighbors
an identity of soil supporters they're
not just making garbage anymore they're
supporting living soil with their food
scraps that they're collecting and then
you can easily see what people accept
and don't accept because people are
different you know some people want to
make vegan soil and other people you
know accept meat and bones and that's
where you sort all that out yeah you
know so it's like an operating system
it's like a global operating system for
humans creating soil together yeah and
then once we do that as we do that
people automatically they want to grow
things a love I love the word soil maker
yeah
yeah it totally increases the level of
like steward that's right just that word
I love it
we need regenerative jobs and so that's
like the like there's people keep this
there's a little bit of talk about a
regenerative economy today but there's
almost no regenerative jobs so the soil
maker is one humble example of what a
regenerative job would look like oh yeah
and as we have those experiences we'll
start to realize all the other
regenerative jobs that could be created
but if this is the time where humanity
is time to create the industries of the
future that will will help us survive
and they're not offered on a college
curriculum right now sadly in most cases
yeah that that's that's a great idea
schools for kids yeah how clothes for
children to get to the soil sites is
just like parents bringing their
children to soil sites like that's a big
yeah I mean field trips bad or sore
parents hosting soil sites you know in
their front yard and having the kids
participate or schools we have some
schools that have become soil sites
that's great I think making soil ought
to be like the center of every earth
science curriculum you know taking from
that abstraction and reading textbooks
about Earth to creating living you miss
that's that would be way more fun for
the kids and there's heat there's like
heat that comes off of this you know
from the microbial activity yeah like
you can get super hot I can get a
hundred and fifty hundred and sixty
hundred seventy degrees and there's
people who at that moment that's when
they really feel and see the planet is
alive there's like they're like where's
the cord is this thing plugged in it's
like no that's microbial activity okay
well okay let's talk about this so um
how does soil get made from compost what
is the act so we've sort of just
rebranded compost as soil because we
found that compost wasn't really like
catching on as a thing and so and and
the bottom line is the the plants pull
carbon out of the air and most people to
be honest don't know that so you can
just a little fun test you can give your
your friend or your roommate or your
spouse or whatever say pointed a big
tree and be like where did that tree
come from and they're like everybody
like what's it made of right it'll be
like they might get the carbon at some
point you know the water and molecules
and car carbon he asked me the carbon
you say where the carbon come from eight
out of 10 people no no some people
you from the ground because it just
looks like it's coming out of the ground
which it kind of is but the vast
majority that carbon is coming out of
the air air so plants are assembling
chains of carbon out of the air from
through photosynthesis and when we turn
it into soil through this composting
process we stabilize what would
otherwise be volatile gases into these
carbon polymers and that's why you can
have something to look at in the palm of
your hand and something to plant the
cement
it's that that so the dots that haven't
connected for Humanity well yeah is that
this mysterious co2 gas in the air can
be turned into this jet-black
life-giving soil in your hand it's just
too abstract to focus right now to eat
so easy so even from the below from the
roots of the tree that's part of the
nutrients that are being that are being
used for the growth process but then
from above were also the plants are also
taking nutrients from above from the am
assess what's getting the carbon done
primarily so the carbon comes from here
and then the nitrogen phosphorous what
was the last one Oh potassium and I
mentioned those three because they're
sort of abused in the in the
agricultural industry people they've
just focused on nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium at the expense of all the
other nutrients but the but the plant
different plants need a great different
variety of nutrients diapers and they
pull most of those out of the soil and
nitrogen which is a gas that's in the
air gets into these little pockets in
the soil and the microbes help create
those pockets through their secretions
and and there's a symbiosis with the
roots through that that pattern of
symbiosis is really is really beautiful
and and if we give the plant what it
needs it'll it'll grow and it will grow
healthy and it'll create food that makes
us healthy and it will be able to defend
itself from pests and things like this
so the the the thing that most people
don't realize is that the the the
nutrients in the soil they're not there
for you and your kids and your family
it's like they're there for the plant
primarily now it works out nicely or
depending on how cosmic you want to get
maybe it is there for us but prime but
it's it's there for the plant as well
and if those nutrients are there the
plant can defend itself and if those
nutrients aren't there then you have to
defend the plant which is very wimpy
from Lights pests and things and we do
that with chemicals which are not good
for us so for the planet and the amount
of topsoil that needs to be regenerated
around the world so basically we're
getting worse and worse in the Arians
over time and yeah we don't seem
depleted take care of the cop I mean
when you just next time you're in a
grocery store just like look at how much
food is there yeah so much and then
realize that a lot of it has a short
expiration date yes and you should see
what's going in the dumpster up act and
realize that you're if you live in a
medium-sized city you probably have five
of those grocery stores yeah and that
there's hundreds of millions of cities
around the world yep and it just doesn't
add up like you could you could you
could show a five-year-old and they
would be like whoa you better be putting
something back in the dirt then you know
yeah yeah
nobody's been confronted with it almost
it's kept that little that little
details kept kept from consumers lest it
curb our purchasing yeah that's a big
one we love talking about how things
work on the show and so that's a big one
when you walk into the grocery store
really think about how all of that food
got there how it was grown
yeah I'm how its transported there where
it's going afterwards yeah I used all
these questions um a couple of things so
when when you're actually taking all of
the scraps from food you were
shepherding the the food waste and then
we're team banana peels coughing there's
all these things what how do if you put
them into a there's a recipe yeah what
is this recipe for making compost
there's many ways to do it but the this
simple kind of nuts-and-bolts way to
explain it is that you're gonna need to
balance the carbon and nitrogen ratio so
if there's too much rowdy stuff in there
if there's too much stuff that if you
were to leave it in your fridge and go
away for a month on the plane you're
like oh no I forgot whatever and I
forgot that fish and the you know in the
fridge that's high in nitrogen so you
balance anything that could rot with
things that are not high in nitrogen
like dry leaves and stuff like this and
when you get the balance just right then
instead of rotting it does a different
thing which is it actively goes through
a microbial process of
composting of earth creation so it's
really that recipe that you teach people
over and over again and it requires a
certain amount of air getting in there
and it requires a certain amount of
moisture so if you just get this recipe
right it's kind like brewing beer it's
kind of learn to the root beer you get
it properly and it makes oil yes okay so
so air and moisture how do we get the
air and moisture in with this nitrogen
and balanced with plant matter yeah so
you can have a little fork or implement
or fluff it up a bit or you can turn it
so people turn their compost times you
get your friends together it's a really
good time on a Friday night this in a
bin like a big well we have we have a
bin on the soy on the site actually yeah
we called the soil maker box and that's
an example of a great device to put it
in but there's many different shapes
does that have like a mesh that has mesh
around it I know the soil stays within
that mesh it does because there's leaves
there's a lot of leaves in there yeah
okay so the idea is that you you can
stir it even fluffier you can a
narrative and okay aerates them them
okay and then you you you get the air
you aerate it through just fluffing it
like that and then you get moisture
coming in from or might add it directly
might add like water it depends because
it hands on weather some people they
don't want to drink the coffee after
it's been sitting out for two hours and
so at their office place they're like
dumping you people see this they're like
dumping the coffee down the drain right
like these poor coffee beans stood in a
jungle for two months transported 3,000
miles and now you're pouring them down
the drain because they got to be two
hours old it's absurd but if you're
taking that liquid so they're not going
down the drain you put that into a
compost pile into the soil making
process okay you wouldn't need to
hydrate it as much right because so
depends on what your your outputs are
right if you have a bunch of I was in
Florida and we were at this have or
orange grove and so like we had 600
rotting oranges in there we didn't need
to add any water right it was
practically orange juice sorry yeah you
just you just start to learn the right
amount of moistness that is you know
this is too much this is too little this
is just right so it's just a simple
recipe that you teach people within a
few months a person get really
proficient at this and then they become
the soil maker for their neighbors
and then their neighbors just start
bringing their scraps and watching the
process and it spreads yeah and we will
spread this to hundreds of millions of
people the question is how quickly can
we do it yeah yeah and then that
experience informs people now that
they've had a regenerative experience
now that they felt what it's like to
help live in harmony with the planet
they start seeing all the places in
their life that are completely out of
harmony it's just a gateway effect yes
you start looking for more ways to and
it feels so much better now they're
putting trash in the garbage can over
here doesn't feel good they're putting
their orange peels and coffee grounds
into this and it does feel good yeah
it's a comparison yeah again that's a
feedback loop not as good feels better
that's how you change behavior yeah yeah
and then that trickles and butterfly
effect or all other aspects of our
that's a divinity on this place that's a
stewardship okay so you can yeah fine
soil set to make soil create soil sites
get going with the communities spread it
to the hundreds of millions of people
Ron and I will be going to one what do
you think we're on do you do you feel
like that this is that has the potential
to do the change that we need in the
world I like what he said earlier about
good Christian supporters and it's not a
liberal hippie plan to do this something
that can bring the community together
regardless of what side you swing on
yeah this is great and thanks for doing
what you do this is so important we get
back to get back to nature on so many
levels because the if we don't we're
gonna be alien greys I say this all the
time there's one soulless organic
species hive mind we got to avoid the
Jetstar
we get him planet Earth
it's a place before the show started Ron
asked Josh if we could eat soil well
like when I was a kid it was on one of
the children's programs the guy put a
little soil on his Apple you know and I
tried doing that my god I think I got a
beating yeah I this just raises the case
of you know what what's the quality of
the soil and so part of the movement
we're taking off here is we create more
and more soil makers as more people join
the ranks of soil makers is there get
we're creating the industry of artisanal
small-batch soil yeah so people start to
Wow
I've seen people who have never
considered the pesticides on their
banana peels and avocados while they
were throwing it into the trash now that
they're putting it into the the box to
make soil they're like wait a minute
those pests aren't there pesticides on
that and they're like oh maybe I should
buy organic next time it's taken that
feedback loop when they thought it was
going away they didn't care now they
realize nothing really goes away it's
not going away
now they care so it's that it's that
gateway experience Wow
Ron will you come with me to make soil
in the bay yeah just drop it off
somewhere find a soil say drop it off
and Ron will you come with sure wait
today awesome no we'll go no we can't we
have our show we have our event tomorrow
but we'll we'll go for those that don't
know identifying and correcting perverse
incentives is happening in San Francisco
tomorrow at 7 p.m. our live event so
yeah you know we'll go we'll go within
by the end of the month we'll go
absolutely this will be a lot of fun
it's always funny when you go and you
like you kind of you dab in gardening a
little bit here and there and then you
grow some tomatoes like I've grown
tomatoes I've grown like like parsley
cilantro like there's these types of
things
I've grown them successfully and then
there are all different types of
conditions have you heard of the food
computer at MIT yet yes you know yeah so
you can actually see all the different
variables that are being computed in
that
vironment for the growth of basil or
tomatoes or whatever and I think that's
really interesting because then it makes
it so that when I fail I can learn and
yeah yeah and some of that it's all
positive that people are paying any
attention to this some of the learning
is erroneous though in reductionist so
you know the computer computer is like
well there you know wasn't enough
selenium in the soil like maybe it'll
tell you that and that's that's fine but
is the answer to like go mind selenium
somewhere and amend the soil with it
right like what are you doing to the
country around the world right so it's
just it it's still this still plenty of
opportunity to get it wrong and the
ultimate answer you want all this data
leading towards the big the big reveal
is that it's not just a raw material
it's a living system and you really need
a living system to be healthy it's not
just one compound of this or that just
like you could have really terrible
relationships at home and we could send
you to the doctor and they'd be like
well your blood works in order right
it's just not a holistic view of your
life that's all it's a piece it's a good
piece though yeah yeah it's yeah it it's
also interesting to think about them on
these like open agriculture like
warehouses of optimizing like literally
can you can you do things like make
basil that that when you eat it helps
you with with like dementia you know
what I mean like that's what they're
also trying to figure out that so many
disorders are just nutrient deficiencies
right if your body doesn't have like
what it needs and I'm not saying they
run out and just by random supplements
because that usually doesn't solve it
but like if your body doesn't have the
the molecules it needs to create the
substrates to create the structures that
support your higher order intelligence
like there's no end to the number of
doctory names we can come up with for
the diseases there's just this they're
gonna proliferate wildly are we gonna
get in trouble because diseases are big
business you know and if we tell people
to get
see and stuff that's gonna cost somebody
billions of dollars yeah such a good
question get mad at yes it's a great
question for the kids ROM that's a great
way to put it that's the bet what about
jobs that's one of the best
interventions that Ron's had on the show
today
that's a great one for young people to
think about like oh yeah well what is
this gonna do for people that are making
money in the medical industry that are
trying to give me a drug instead to fix
that ailment instead of me exercising or
going and eating more healthy or
sleeping more and that's a fantastic
approach to thinking about is that there
are forces that are trying to get people
yeah yeah this is saying like what you
consider waste somebody else can cause
their job what one man's junk is another
man's treasure and then so then this is
a nonprofit and I better know there's
there's better jobs for everybody is we
don't need to be in a soy acres and so
you know somebody might lose their job
if we start fixing society but the good
news is they're gonna be much happier in
their new job their new regenerative job
that's in harmony with the planet and
that's what's crazy is people people
will lose a job they're used to that
they didn't really like I hurt their
back was no good for their mind and
because the curiosity has been destroyed
because the mind has been abused in so
many ways they cannot think of anything
better to do with themselves and they
will just pick it and Sue and do
whatever they can to get that terrible
job back that they didn't really want
kids which is why I'm into the
consciousness thing as well you know we
heal the human mind and then people can
make better choices and think of better
things to do with themselves yeah which
we all do increasingly you know yeah and
this also I think reminds us a lot of
how people can go out and just organize
a very small gathering for for
exercising as well and then going on
just like doing some connecting to the
park that they're in or to the doing
some yoga or some exercises in the park
these types of things these are the
little bits of like organizing
communities
go and make soil or to exercise or to go
and learn some sort of a game where they
play these like authentically dating
games I mean we're talking game over
once humans are moving in that direction
there's a tipping point that happens the
consciousness goes up so high if I can
win the wisdom race it's true and
there's a transition period though which
we have to be sensitive to which is that
right now the way the economy works
people need jobs right so there's people
out there who have kids and they're just
like they're like we can look at their
calendar and they do not have much time
for authentic relating games in the park
I need a job programming at Zynga so I
can make games I mean they pay me a
hundred thousand a year that's like what
I take a job that pays me 30,000 a year
I can't live in SF I have two kids and
that all changes if you and your
neighbors are growing all your food in
your backyard right if every if you have
an avocado tree here and a walnut tree
there and this neighbor grows these four
veggies in 30 minutes a week and your
other neighbor grows these three veggies
in 30 minutes a week and then you you
see that abundance you see where food
comes from you see that you're not gonna
starve you can chill out and decide
maybe you learn a new skill maybe I'll
get a different job well what do I want
to be next you sit down with your
friends and you eat and you talk about
it so that's another reason why it's
such a kind of first domino to tip over
of people making soil together because
then people grow food together then
people have real food security you're
not on some space-age AI supply chain
system that's still out there somewhere
but because we just know how to plant
the seeds and put them in the ground to
take care of them and it's fun that's
real security and then and then our
higher-order thinking comes online and
we can create a better world together
and then what is the I mean this is okay
this is a non-profit yeah this so so you
guys can donate to make soil help them
grow as well yeah but going get involved
in your communities make sites in your
communities especially where you have so
much space across the world we have so
many places that have space outside of
Metropolis yeah but try and make it so
the next time you play in a building
that there's a garden on the top these
types of things in the future maybe we
can talk to Bob and see if we can get
those pins on the roof and you know we
got enough people here that might have
yeah actually Ron's rounds right we
could put one of those bins on the roof
that's that's a great idea yeah it is
it's a fantastic idea and another aspect
to that is that it can't cost that
that's the thing is that like it can't
cost the management money or time but if
the people say that we're gonna do this
ourselves and you don't have to do
anything we're doing it ourselves we're
gonna organize it as a community I like
that one too Ron I feel good when I'm a
good writer make sure to write that one
down at the top of this talk to Bob yeah
let's see let's see what he says about
that we'll keep you guys posted on what
on what he says about Pastor Bob what do
you think if we start saving the planet
like a roof garden yeah yeah a roof
compost we've soil yeah I think he's
just gonna yeah we don't want you going
on the roof yeah that's that's what it's
right there's a liability there your
give it we'll give it a go to see what
happens the great American virtue is the
creative you um can let's also talk
about the other come okay we talked
about this a little bit earlier but
there is this wisdom race that's
happening with our need to raise our
consciousness become more spiritually
stewards of the planet because
exponential technology is becoming
democratized of one's ability to do
happy a malevolent actor is is
announcing the geopolitical situation is
not a hundred million people that are
somewhat Disgaea from a planet NOW it's
eight billion people that disconnect
from planets so so how do we how do we
how do we how do we handle that other
than making soil together yes making
soil together a fantastic one
how do we what how do we what do we do
about this about this the spiritual
intervention that Oh ending at the
craziness of the Exorcist technology
time yeah like healing healing the mind
is a good idea like yeah everybody's
carrying tons of guilt fear and shame
and bottling it up and you know there
were their whole generations before us a
lot of our parents where it was a real
mark of shame to go to a therapist or
something like that
right I've I've personally had I've had
hundreds of therapy sessions right and
probably maybe a thousand therapy
sessions a hundreds of modalities 104
modalities I just like once you realize
that intelligence is a thing in your
mind and your emotions and all that
stuff are kind of running your life then
yeah it just really behooves you to
upgrade the mind and repair the mind and
and elevate consciousness and really
like I'm not I'm not the whole political
thing is so gnarly right I don't I get
into a political conversation but I what
I will say is that the the level of
governance and government and politics
that we need to survive as a species is
inversely proportional to our
enlightenment so when people can
regulate themselves when they're not
when I'm not projecting my bad shot my
my difficult childhood with painful
memories and being bullied in the
schoolyard onto you as you today are the
problem which is what most of what goes
on in the world then we have a lot less
issues and we need a lot fewer laws a
lot less court cases an inverse
relationship between spiritual
enlightenment and governance yeah did
you hear that one Ron Ron Ron Ron Ron
sucks
Ron talks about that one a lot but the
need that we we don't need to be
governed and and the the the if we are
spiritually enlightened then we don't
need governance but when we're not
spiritually enlightened then we need to
be governed yeah what
out there yes as much as I for
self-governance it may take a couple of
more civilization just you know it's I
don't have any hopes of it future
juncture I appreciate what you're doing
I'm doing this either way you can scream
yeah likewise likewise yeah yeah that's
the mentality actually everyone I want
you to put a flag in exactly what Josh
just said I'm doing this
either way I'm doing this regardless
that's what separates the some of the
most brilliant entrepreneurs and artists
creators on the planet is that they
don't care how much they have to suffer
in order to build the future that they
want to change change can I continue
going to the bar even if I we have a
utopian future can I still go course you
can do whatever you want with your time
yeah yeah yeah can you go to the bars
are you guys to have a MCT cacao kava
elixir okay and then how about what are
the forces that are at play on planet
earth that are beyond our physical
reality with this question comes natural
little segue there yeah because we were
talking you earlier I don't know how but
we were yeah there's there's there's as
I told you I'm just into reality right
and so I just I love trying to parse
reality as much of reality as I possibly
can and we can talk at the level of the
biosphere we can talk at the level of
society we can talk at the level of the
mind we can talk at the level of
technology and computers and code and
circuitry and one massive element of
hubris for rational people who love to
talk about all any of the things I just
mentioned is that they believe that the
top level is with them in their own ego
and that's absurd hmm right so really
reality is very fractal there's patterns
all around us and those patterns play
out at different levels so in the same
way that each individual has a brain
that has a bunch of neurons to help
create who you are clearly each of us is
like a neuron in a larger brain and so
there's a bunch of neurons talking to
each other in my head right now and that
allows me to act like a neuron and this
is our sin house with Ron here oh that's
beautiful yes and so like is there a
higher power there has to be there's
whatever there's whatever field of
consciousness we create together each
acting as a neuron and maybe it goes far
beyond that as well yeah we've heard
about the eight billion humans being
like and all of the sentience in the
animals the plants they insect etc being
guy at this biosphere at all being
interconnected as in neurons right and
then I love how you describe the
interconnection between us as the
synapse the space and then so we're new
neurotransmitter yeah
but through talking yeah and I took the
ticket took neuroplasticity for me to
get here right I moved myself physically
and we put our you know we're here so
that our dendrites can touch and we're
in the room and yeah right yeah what's a
dendrite yeah there's a shampoo for that
[Laughter]
Ron just the hump just kind of consider
investigating the complexity of the
smallest parts of the neuronal
infrastructures of the brain Ron Ron Ron
quickly races to his news feed when he
has time so I'm just trying to see yeah
I know she's very important yeah serious
news Ron okay
all right and then are we in a
simulation I like to say that you could
say that but I what I like to say and
you don't have to change the name of
your show just because of this but I
think it's I like to give it more as an
interface
so see what I what I there are many
simulation like dynamics to this but
what what I don't love as much about
that is that some people think it
doesn't matter sure and I think this is
like yes this is the simulation that
also matters a lot
yeah and in another way of doing some of
the exclusive things yeah yeah yeah but
if you also think it was an interface
like this is like whether your cosmology
is that like you're a soul who
incarnated here to do something then
this is the interface for working on
yourself for mature soul or whatever or
but this is an interface it's a school
yeah just like there's a graphical user
interface of like you would take a mouse
or a touchpad and you would interact
with another system like this body is
your interface into this system and your
mind is your interface and I like that
yeah I like the word interface a lot
yeah and out of all the people that
we've asked that you came back with
another unique cool word I like
interface a lot and a lot of people
actually don't find those things
mutually exclusive but if it is a
simulation yeah interface or so don't
come here to school but yeah it doesn't
matter yeah yeah it actually a lot of
people on the show say that it really
matters yeah fantastic
totally and that usually we need more
children to believe that that it matters
that their purpose in the world matters
and to find their purpose as quickly as
possible and to not get sucked in the
Joker vortexes but to do cool things
like yeah oil and to become better
stewards it's some people use it very
conveniently for themselves which I
always like to poke fun at like where
like somebody will like be asking me
about like they really need funding for
their company or something right and
it's like really serious like they need
funding you know and or they can't do
this company or it's gonna fall a fail
or whatever and then I'll be talking
about like the environment and the issue
with the biosphere and they're not into
that at all they don't know anything
about it and then they're just like well
look it's just look this isn't reality
anyway it's the simulation Lego a tab if
you'd like to you care if you get the
money or not then because it's like
you've been really passionate about the
simulation a minute ago okay it's just
it's just awareness and so in spiritual
in the whole spiritual world this word
awareness gets thrown around a lot but
it's like laughably simple what
awareness
it means awareness of everything it
means awareness of like this awareness
of my posture there's awareness of my
emotions is awareness of my impact of
consuming the biosphere and then I'm
completely unaware of where it goes when
I put it in that plastic bag like that's
awareness - it's all valid yeah so more
awareness is great but it's not limited
to like the kind of awareness you get
after yoga class yeah you know yeah and
then what is the most beautiful thing in
the world the most beautiful thing one
that's coming to mind is that anybody if
anybody stops for even five minutes to
ask themselves can I imagine a more
beautiful world and specifically what I
would change every single person will
get a vision back and if every single
person took a step toward that vision
we'd have heaven on earth it's a
distributed problem it's a distributed
job it's not meant to be fixed by some
one person I love that can I envision a
more beautiful earth how how would I
make that yeah
and for some people it's gonna be all
they're gonna go to this nursing home
and take take kids too and then I take
them down to the daycare where they
don't have enough people to watch the
kids and for somebody else that'll be
making soil together yes yeah for
somebody everybody it's just for
somebody else that'll be accepting
themselves or helping other people have
self-acceptance or whatever it is but
each person is a distributed to
distribute a problem and we're a
distributed network you're gonna solve
it together yeah Wow
planetary interventions and what a great
show yeah Thank You Josh thank you for
coming so much fun but last
thank you thank you mmm love it thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also have more conversations of your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about the
importance of going out and making soil
go out and make soil go attend the sites
go and create your own sites go and do
that everyone's so crucial and also talk
more about the other planetary
interventions that we need go and make
your planetary interventions happen find
the links in the bio to make soil orga
as well as Josh Witten all the social
pages find all those links in the bio
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronnie
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders and
organizations around the world that you
believe in support them support
simulation our links are below
PayPal patreon cryptocurrency design
cool merch and get paid help support us
and go and build the future everyone
manifest those dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in we'll see you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
cool give me